it has been my dream to be first in line
for any Apple Store event and I mean
like this is it like we're here we're
first we're first
[Music]
in oh my goodness it's like honestly
it's going to be great just leave it oh
oh hello windshield clo my gosh wait I
have a side car I have a side window
good you're going to need some air oh my
gosh you look like you're in a dog house
we're beginning the camp out we're
waiting for Ed and JB JB's coming later
Ed will be here very shortly Jenna is
here starting to get hungry me too but
the problem is is Sun is creeping in
slowly
creeping I'm going to need to put some
sunscreen on so we have our first
visitor here Cameron hey what's up yeah
you're not going to wait here though are
you I'm not going to wait here I'm
waiting for a new phone but I have I
think I'm going to I can't I can't wa 2
days Justine I'm crazy I'm insane but
there's a juice bar right there I know
and there's like Starbucks and coffee
like everywhere so I mean knowing you I
know we were joking that we were going
to do a juice Blend and guess what
during your iPhone waight I know we
won't have to worry about food and
there's a juice bar right there just
like roll up so what's your YouTube
channel U my YouTube channel is James
Cameron Phillips and my daily channel is
Cameron daily well this is really
exciting I know I was like I just is she
waiting already it's literally Wednesday
you guys I know the phone goes on sale
on Friday morning at 8:00 first snack
stop we had to do it how's it going down
there all right I'm really excited
though cuz we have a really really great
musician performing I'm going to have to
go find her name because she's
[Music]
awesome my she's amazing like she's so
good so I have to edit a video now so
I'm going to edit the video inside of my
tent but I need it for shade right now
and I got got to get my iOS 8 video up
time
check 2:14 2:14 um got some
umbrellas
guys it's hot all right it is 2:53 p.m.
on Wednesday we've got the third person
in line so we're here at the Apple Store
and I told you that I was going to be
auctioning off my phone for charity and
this is so crazy but I met Cody here hey
hi and so he heard heard that we were
going to be auctioning this off and he
let me know about this charity and I
don't actually have all the information
about the charity but I will have it in
my email soon and thanks to Cody we
found it I've got an iPhone here too are
you going to be upgrading to the new
iPhone it'll be like that big do you
think that'll be better for you yeah
well Cody it was so great meeting you
you made this entire Apple Store
experience so much more fun so you're
amazing
yay you're the best let's fix your hair
there you go
say
bye so we've been out here I don't even
know what time is what time is it it's
5:18 uh we got this dude over here I
don't know what he's doing he's like
daning in the bottle do you think like I
should I go join him I don't I mean he's
got two Hoops he's got two Hoops how
many there he's three he has three Hoops
three where'd he go come back come back
sir come back guys I'm so excited I just
got my new phone this is the iPhone 6 I
can't believe it's already out I got it
a little bit early I just actually ran
into the Apple Store and I took it 8:30
p.m. here's our
line we have another person coming to
join the line I don't remember oh two
dudes walk by Dustin and Justin no the
other one has I don't know oh my
go up do I want to bunk
up holy
[__] I can't believe this is happening
but it is night time
should what I would like oh man is it
going to be as big as this
one what's that Galaxy S5 it's bigger
bigger D phone yes oh they finally set
the game
up [__] they got CAU it doesn't have
regular super oh you got to trampoline
I'm half asleep I don't know what's
happening it's reach just them oh speech
yeah yes what is it called stay hungry
stay foolish yeah yes oh yeah one of the
best speeches I ever heard
of I don't think I'm having fun I don't
think Ed's having
fun time now is
7:55
Thursday my motivation and my spirit is
really not
well my mind is not
well they just brought the barri ades in
8:00 a.m.
September potentially 18th the
barricades arrive The Crowd Goes
Wild
moving into the
line all right it's
12:31 you got your umbrella we see you
guys
bye can you please show them my tent
that I've crafted Shield myself from the
Sun it looks great thank you I might
actually be joining you I highly
recommend it maybe we should get a juice
and you pH join yeah but we've
officially been here over a day this is
the line so we're up
here
um Hello friends hello hi so you guys
you guys are set up now this is nice for
the B looks good looks good I mean this
we've got some really crafty thing this
is a great
idea tonight that's what we have to do
this is great this is oh my God this is
like a really really long line hello
hello hey how are you just just visiting
yeah it's been an hour and what's wrong
I fell asleep and it's only been an hour
oh no it's hot I it's really
hot this is the line guys I think I'm
I'm losing my mind and Thursday oh my
God I keep looking at the time and I
keep forgetting at 4:30 p.m. we have
what 14 more
hours how's it
going I paid her $10,000 to be first in
line I didn't actually you the first
person yeah we are take a selfie with
you yeah we're both walk I just oh
that's what I just
seen I really like your shirt hold on
I'm like getting Stu the most exciting
thing that could ever happen in the past
two days look who has showed up to the
line crazy ass is here she's getting the
bone tomorrow so you guys are really
pranking the line is that what you like
we need we're trying to think of ideas
all right think of something I'll think
of something um I'm I'm not I'm I can't
even speak right now you're going be on
the news when you come out you're the
first one they filmed so you got to do
something no Justin you got to do
something crazy come on you got to do
something crazy okay we'll think of it
think all right you got to like make
some controversy stuff about it I was
think you should pull it out you should
pull it out yeah I got it an iPod like I
got it but it's so much bigger than I
was expecting look how big it is the IP
IP iPad iPad that's actually really
funny I do have it with me you got to do
something you got to do something be so
I was just watching walking back and
this looks so silly our little setup
here so silly look at this silly silly
setup and Suzy
woo we're walking back I'm like look
this just so
silly okay what's your
name I didn't I was like I'm pretty sure
at rman I saw you oh my gosh I was like
you look familiar that's hilarious
so there you go thank you can I get
picture with
you I think there's some myphones being
delivered that's a lot of phones want to
hear
joke my iPhone is UPS it's not in that
box this is all we've been waiting
for front row Splash Zone getting hands
up get
real oh yeah you posted this online
didn't you I did yeah oh my God that's
we can't show this oh this we posted way
hello
hello how are you
I'm look at you you got your you got
your
GoPro
you're iPhone
6 we found you how are you well I saw
your Instagram I knew you were here
we're hunting you down you're still
we'll go on this side oh yeah come over
here I have a question yes made it
technically you're second we made it we
made it we made it I was worried cuz I
we drove past and I didn't
outside like where the you look
great you get you don't even get the
first just you honestly I don't even
care at this point mess up you messed up
Apple fan it's good to see you though
you too bar and I was just like let's go
and see them oh go this is awesome we
just drove up p and was like go say hi
the news yay we just interviewed Justine
and I photo bombed your interview I'm
sorry did you it's okay hopefully they
leave it cuz I did one of these joints
yeah the news everyone's like oh my gosh
the news is everyone's going to be here
we like so far fo fo I here first on the
scene we have
I so guys why aren't you in line did you
guys pre-order or what's up yeah I
didn't because I need a new contract
right 12:26 morning of the Apple
iPhone release I have to get some sleep
Ed what's up man I'm probably going to
go take my second to last of the night
nice just in case all right time for bed
it's about uh it's a little after
midnight the store is all closed up
we've had lots of visitors my camera is
not straight because I don't know why
but there we go 6: a.m. I'll be awake
Ed's over there friends are all over
there the Line is now wrapping around
the block so when the Apple employees
get here tomorrow I think they're going
to be really shocked because I don't
think they're expecting us it's going to
be crazy let's go home and play Destiny
wait
look look at
it uh I'm going to go to Barney's and
play have fun I'll uh I'll be here all
right watch more stuff okay where's your
actual stuff JB it is JB I actually
thought you were not um with us you did
not look like you were friend look like
us can you see
me she needle she robs this guy food
card and then tells a sheriff
isart pH
so kid Chuck comes down he's been taking
out hi it's 5:30 uh the day of iPhone
launch feeling really not the freshest
of the fresh Jenna oh my gosh hello I
forgot to change my shirt getting some
sandwiches for our crew hello waiting oh
my gosh how I would hug you but I'm
disgusting all sorts of [__] no you're
not disgusting how are you I'm good I've
been better why I've been sleeping on
the street come on You Been Just sck 3
days no big deal I know but I I think
I'm getting sick now so that's not fun
but yay oh my gosh I'm very excited do
an
emergency you guys said 6:00 a.m. so we
tried to hurry no they're coming out no
no get up there oh my God what are you
doing look how giant that phone is all
right it's an iPad it is an iPad the C
wo that phone's big I eat my breakfast
guys it's the size of an iPad I'm
returning it right is the size of an
iPad what the wow CH how do you feel I
feel like an
idiot but I'm
excited this is
[Music]
exciting we're here still so we're
making our first run to the car to take
our things I'm actually I don't I can't
say I'm sad that to see this day end
because I'm not I'm tired I'd like to go
home now did they get to you yet not yet
sadly but you're close you're close good
luck good luck I mean this thing is
going all the way
around all the way down here all the way
up there pre-order line JB first in
line coffee got shelter then and most
importantly we've got the phones resered
do you want to buy climb in there um
I'll get out well I know I didn't mean
with you getting out get
out very cozy quite cozy guys how's it
going number one oh number three you're
number one well we met some really good
friends here in line it's been a really
fun experience would you say it's fun or
yeah what's the first thing you're going
to do when you get home wait you have to
go to work oh gosh I got hello hello is
everybody excited yay
y I promise you I you
excited the enthusiasm that we have it
might look a little uh not enthus we are
excited we're just really
tired okay the time is now I hope my
phone doesn't die or camera Jeff how are
you feeling don't care just
kidding are you
tired how are you This Is Our Big
Moment everyone's exhausted I have no
energy left at all it's okay I drank all
that coffee went right into a weird spot
in my body it's not doing
anything I smell like rock I smell like
feces wait yeah y right here right yeah
it's definitely it no what is happening
I don't know but Cody's got the best
shot he's got the
GoPro
wow guys thanks for
waiting and you're welcome what kind
of that was so
[Applause]
[Music]
good
[Applause]
W all
right
woo
it's better to get them now
versus we're going to get we're going to
get you
one always
do wow that's real
sharp look at
it all right we got Cody's oh my God I
almost iPad's iPhone
Y how exciting
wait I'm making my first phone call my
first phone call is to Cody's mom I
haven't left the voicemail in like
honestly 5 years that's like a real big
chin hi this is Justine so we're at the
Apple
Store I just want like you know this is
the the second phone that was purchased
here in the store today oh thank you so
much it's so nice of you stay in line
for me look if I was going to get it for
anybody I'd get it from more so you're
awesome
very exciting Cody here we go I iorder
the red one but oh there it
is
awesome here it
is yeah the Lea yeah that's what I'm wor
cor so exciting Lamar this is our friend
Cody we met him in line hi Cody our
friend Lamar how are you he does a lot
of tech stuff
he also has a YouTube channel I haven't
seen it yet though but I'm excited do
you want to set up new or
back it's going to take a while to do
that all right we're leaving the Apple
Store it is now 10 a.m. I've been here
for
a got the
phone uh it all worked out and Lamar got
his phone yes I did so happy and isn't
have his phone yet you stayed in line
all that time Cody got my phone Cody got
your phone
oh here we
go Cody got his phone Cody got his phone
bye Cody we'll talk to you
[Music]
soon
a